[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts I
had a baseball coach once his son his
son this is baseball practice is playing
second base and he was not and they
would ask that whoever was playing
catcher at the time hey he would say to
him if anyone's not paying attention let
me know because that was the whole thing
you have to be like on your toes and he
said oh I forgot his son's name was
David he's like oh David's not paying
attention and this coach turns around
with the baseball a fully grown man and
threw the ball as hard as he could not
his son's head it was like a [ __ ]
cartoon I swear to God his son bent down
because I'm not making stuff a butterfly
was flying under the dirt and his son
went to go cup the butterfly and the
ball missed his head by that much where
even my father who was crazy and would
call me slurs if I if I struck out was
like don't [ __ ] do that again he was
like you do that again you're gonna have
to deal with me and I was like Wow
insane that's insane I mean he would
have killed his son in the name of
Little League Baseball shout out to rgmv
oh my God yeah that is insane that he
was that gay to bend over to pick up a
butterfly
okay how the [ __ ] did you get I remember
when you I think you sent this email out
that like FX your series is I'm like how
do you get your series from FX yeah it's
kind of crazy I don't think anybody's
done that no
well FX
um took my series off I don't know why
what the [ __ ] it's so weird it was
really successful and then they just
made an arbitrary decision that's weird
to just I mean I was baffled I was like
guys why we're like it's just the
feeling we have but I was like that's
weird guys so new CEO they always do
[ __ ] like that that's the thing I ever
thought of that yeah there wasn't one
but maybe it's something like that dude
one time
um
my mom I was touching myself and uh
and I was a child you know yeah and my
mom came in and then she's like uh I was
like get out you know how did y'all get
out at her and she went out and then and
I kept doing it she just came right back
in
crazy of her why was she coming back in
I don't know maybe proud proud of you I
don't think she was ever proud of me all
right
me too that's why I've been doing this
now so my mom caught me once I had a
towel or I just gotten out of the shower
I was a little little boy I remember
because I was like this is when I was
jerking off like 12 times a day it was
incredible I thought I had found the
newest [ __ ] crypto you know what I
mean yeah
and she came in so I had a towel on
right and she came in and and I sort of
like turned around you know I'm like oh
God get away get away whatever and she's
like what the [ __ ] is going on over
there and because it was a towel and
back then you know when you're younger
it like really [ __ ] like sticks up
you know what I mean yeah and she just
saw like this like vibrating thing like
just this little basically out tick like
a sideways CP if you will yeah anyway
then then we had sex no yeah I don't
know there's no end of the story I'm
sorry this is also Bearing Buddy good
boy why don't you cooperate there's
meant to be an emotional support animal
you know anyways I got like I went to
the doctors and got an emotional support
animal card and you have to support him
every day they're unrelenting support
that you require I double blast myself
though because like I went to get the
dog so that I could take him places but
then I realized when I can't take him
places I'm antagonized by it and like it
freaks me out so I've actually do
require
so big to take anywhere like you can't
fly with this guy it makes you nervous
yeah you gotta run a private jet he's
just sliding around it's gonna be a
whole thing he's scampering about the
place you'd be better off with a
terrorist
at least there's a chance because they
say you can't negotiate with terrorists
but you actually can yeah just give them
a try that's what you have to do what
are your needs what is the historic
problem that you're trying to address
otherwise what's gonna happen cycle of
violence they're perpetuating a cycle of
violence right so I might get an
emotional support terrorist I don't know
what if you don't cooperate you're
married I am you yeah I am no kids no
kids yeah 13 and 10. holy [ __ ] yeah dude
what's going on the whole [ __ ] thing
dude two kids 13 10 dog cats
I just my I don't say no dude camera
no there you go liar Enzo fan of art I'm
a creator of it we have very different
they're very different opinion it's true
we have very different opinions on
things I am a creator of art Ben is like
a fanboy so we have different we have
different reactions but he did direct a
Netflix special and by the way
I don't think people ask to understand
how difficult it is to direct a Netflix
special because you stand up comedy
special because you have to point the
cameras at the stage
it is one of the hardest things that
anyone has ever done which is why every
member of Ben's family has tagged him 95
times in the thing that says directed by
Ben Avery because they're so proud of
him and they have a reason to be proud
of him because the people that shot the
special work for Louis CK and Joe Rogan
this group of people so they were
incredibly new at this they were novices
they had only done what four specials
with Joe and four with Louis or
something
they they hadn't done a lot
so Ben made sure that they all pointed
the cameras in the direction of the
stage
and not I don't know the lobby of the
theater or
someone else
how was it working with it what were the
what were the the real challenges of the
uh the challenges of getting the cameras
at this to face the stage well uh first
of all I was thwarted immediately
because I tried to leave all the lens
caps on the cameras when they were
shooting because I was actually trying
to sabotage the whole thing well but no
let's think about it your family's
incredibly proud of you about this
and
they're very proud
and
do they do they understand that they any
of them could have done this
let do your brothers and mother
understand that they too could have done
this uh thing that you did
should we say they are also executive
producers I wonder if Tim would have sex
with me did we talk about this before we
did I don't remember this I don't know I
think you said yes he would I think he
said me before you without Whitney
you want to call Tim nope okay let's
leave it up in the air okay
um that would be no offense I'd be
genuinely offended if it was you before
me for real yeah
dude you realize Tim definitely I'm more
his type than you are I don't know that
how would I know that because we're just
just hanging out with him you know that
he looks at a guy like me and goes that
is a guy I could fall in love with
you're like you're not that you're not
that guy
okay but you're not you're not you
people don't look at you and go people
look at me and go I could fall in love
with him what
hold on hold on let's [ __ ] Park here
for a second so you think if you think
someone let's put it on Instagram
there's people watching right now who
put in the comments put in the [ __ ]
comments
when you just look at us when you just
look at us
and you go
all right who could I fall in love with
not
who can I be in a relationship with whoa
we mean that we're gonna be a
relationship with falling in love with
people like there's people I can fall in
love with it very quickly
like okay like there's people I can go
oh I that person's got the juju then I
could fall in love with I could fall in
love with them there's something about
them where I go
after the first night of cuddling we got
up and just everything about the guy
where he gets up and this is all me but
he's like gets up and he's like what are
we gonna do for lunch today you know and
you're like you're not that way you're
like I'm getting coffee and I think
that's hard to fall in love with you go
um what are you doing and you're on your
phone you're like Googling Porsches
like I'm more like hey what are you
doing on your phones people fall in love
with that easier
that is so insane how you think really
quick thank you for watching this video
so far I want to let you know that we're
going to be doing this every month
moving forward so please comment any
comedians podcasts or shows that I
missed in this video that you think
deserve to be in the best of September
and while you're here please subscribe
to joke world there's going to be a lot
of videos in between now and the best of
September that I think you would enjoy
if you're enjoying this video lots of
highlights from podcasts best moments
from Comedians and a comedy news update
that we do every single Monday bring you
the news from the coming world of the
previous week so please subscribe if you
love comedy You Don't Want to Miss a
Thing joke world right now and enjoy the
rest of this video I love being a dad
whoops thank you
yeah it's great and my son's awesome and
uh he's so great and my parents are like
yo you you you were he's not a an
[ __ ] like this sucks you son of a
[ __ ] you know what I mean you an
[ __ ] two and a half I mean every ball
babies are you know I was probably I
wasn't how do you know what hold on you
weren't no my mom has told me that she
took you to the doctor because I was
smiling too much and she thought
something was wrong wow dude that's
creepy so you were creepy as [ __ ] you
smile too much it could be a [ __ ] I have
autism
what are you gonna do canceled what are
you gonna do cancel me
yeah never did Kill I heard it was the
worst stand up Kimmel yeah because uh
they would take everybody to another
room and then you do you perform so
everybody's like what the [ __ ] I
remember Geraldo said on there that was
like great yeah great jokes and just
nothing they were they would be nothing
I never saw that one yeah uh and now and
now they do it I think in his comedy
club in Vegas you're not even on set
yeah you're in Vegas you gotta do it
that way in Vegas yeah yeah at a club
for sure in Vegas well because you don't
even feel like you're doing the show
it's it's just I would rather do it he's
probably helping you out as opposed to
just going out there with those people
you know just got off the [ __ ]
Pirates of the Caribbean ride and then
you go up there with your [ __ ] Hitler
joke and they're just like
and all you ever hear is the band
laughing and you want to be like like
the band is laughing okay this this is
uh this is doing I'm doing well here
yeah it's funny how nervous those Crowds
Are I did a thing on Fallon like two
weeks ago and I threw out a joke and I
remember thinking like this is gonna hit
and it got zero and it's the worst
feeling because you're like that is on
tape and now Fallon hates me if I rode
Robb Bank I'd walk in with a real baby a
real baby someone else's baby yeah and
the highest don't move where the baby
gets it oh I'm a kindergarten teacher
I'm off my ship I'm on my nap time don't
move
I'd bring in a baby and I go do you want
this baby to live yeah but it's not he
could bring race into it it's got to be
a white baby value is that what it is I
don't know do you think I'm just asking
I don't think white babies are the most
expensive anymore yeah what do you think
the most expensive white baby is any
non-white
because the culture Shanks culture yeah
yeah times have changed it's a different
time black baby then black baby cute
black baby black baby yeah yeah I think
a mix baby and you don't know what it is
yeah a couple looking a nation baby a
couple of Canadian and then that thing
is worth as much money as you I mean
yeah there's an Instagram for mixed race
babies yeah mixed race babies Instagram
yeah
that's wild people just how many
followers more than all of us no 243 is
really good look at that girl right
there
I mean that's something we bring that
girl nobody knows what she is that that
girl people like oh here's my money
here's my money take my money yeah look
at how good looking this mixture is oh
my God yeah look at how good looking
this mixed race man do you want this
mixed race baby to live are you woke are
you walking
up right oh that one oh [ __ ] they won't
even know they're being robbed they'll
just beginner the bank will just be like
oh my God open the vault look at how
cute that [ __ ] kid is yeah what about
a baby with Down Syndrome we'll be right
back
I told you I would call the special
needs people Westchester the squeezers
who said that me and my buddy because we
used to go we used to go to the
cafeteria we're the only dudes in my
group of friends that enjoyed the
Westchester cafeteria because it was
like first of all it was all you can eat
it's the cheapest one yeah it's the
worst food by far but it was the
cheapest one for like four different
cereals on Deck there it was so nice it
was crazy but we mean me and Tommy would
go get lunch and then one day the
squeezers the squeezers will get lunch
at the same time as us yeah yeah there's
this group of special needs people and
one day this girl grabbed the ketchup
and went and [ __ ] it dude it hit the
ceiling I'm not kidding the ketchup oh
my God exploded at the table all the
[ __ ] people
the ketchup drone strike dude squeeze it
ceiling and everyone at the table it was
uh I'll never forget how happy I was
dude the squeezers I hear this what are
their Bros what did the Bros say when
they got hit it was star startling in
The Chaperone had to like you know be
like everyone's all right
it's literally Code Red
oh
sat down they all just sat down with
their [ __ ] trays dude they probably
just got changed from a previously
sloppy shirt they gotta change them
again
[Applause]
it's like when a baby shits and then
shits again you're like Jesus
when ketchup is totally full it still
has the like seal inside the cap so
that's what she squeezed through what
and it just oh my God
I mean I'm telling you there was a giant
like ceilings this High to use a
cafeteria it explode it hit the ceiling
low ceilings it's like two stories
it was nuts
luckily there's a box of Marvin the
Martian t-shirts
for free credit cards on campus
yeah squeezers that's the best squeezers
damn see them all get decimated with
catch up mostly that's okay that was
also a low point for me too like sitting
in that cafeteria looking at the
squeezers being I was at West Point
West points cafeteria looks like
Hogwarts it's [ __ ] incredible now I'm
in this like with office lighting
squeezers
oh my God I had one guy come over with a
we were at we were at my cousin's house
it was like a little bit of more distant
you know what I mean it wasn't like
really enough were you really in the
fold yeah and he had a friend though
like that Uncle or whoever had a friend
over I don't know who this guy was he
still gets made fun of 25 years later he
broke out an acoustic guitar in front of
a bunch of [ __ ] you know a bunch of
pipefitters exactly sheetrock for a
living and it was no way Jose because
I'm a joker
yeah that's getting barreled into
toothpicks over his forehead dude Uncle
Ray ain't having any of that [ __ ]
what a steel tips directly yeah yeah
guys would still have spackle on their
hands I'm gonna sit there and watch you
play Freebirds
bring an instrument to that party when
you're a kid
that's a bloodbath just showing up there
better be an instrument there better be
24 highlights in a guitar case
we were on a plane one time and the
pilot got on and had a guitar in his
back I was like ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
Jesus Christ that was about one
Christmas party I got a karaoke somebody
I think must be a karaoke machine and my
mom made me
oh no
a little tough guy my dad would have
like I know you had a daughter
he's wearing his mom's juicy sweatsuit
holy [ __ ]
on some fake gold I'm gonna look like
JLo
I'm still Kippy
[Laughter]
ah there's a fat kid in velor
hitting the wrong notes
these [ __ ] moose knuckles sticking
out oh you stink I could not picture
that scene so clearly I remember my
Uncle Dan turning around
I can't look at you right now pilot
goggles on here
so he narrows it down to me and one
other guy
and at this point Barstool is not what
it is today it's a risk you know and I'm
like I got this money and this good job
and he comes back and he says I can't
decide between you two how about you
split the job split the writing and you
can split the money and keep your old
job and I'm like perfect so now I can do
both I'm making a little extra money and
for two years I did both jobs nobody at
my accounting firm knew that I was a
blogger none of the blog readers knew
that I was an accountant
so I was kind of doing this double life
thing eventually Barstool grows big
enough I grow uh to the point that I'm
getting fired they were like they were
like why don't we talk about
transferring you to another department
because you know things are not working
out and I was like I'm good man I'm good
I'm trying to get fired because I want a
severance package I want to keep my
Cobra benefits and they're not getting
they're not getting it bro
yeah I need that code yeah dude I've had
a bunch of surgeries and [ __ ] like
needed people like I need that I gotta
eat their Cobra dog it's like half price
man yo it really is but I mean I've had
I had I've had three shoulder surgeries
two back surgeries and neck surgery I
can't now I'm not one of those guys and
I asked Dave about insurance and he's
like yeah okay bud yeah sure thing it's
called be careful yeah I got the
earliest flight out on Monday I land at
10 30 a.m I'm like this is going to be
perfect I'll show up everybody will be
just getting up when I call this Sunday
to set it all up list goes
this goes well here's the I'm listening
it's sizzling listen to that how good is
that sound
that's the um
eat it eat it eat it no don't put that
right in your tongue it's like a battery
is it good
yeah chart about something cooked hot
dog
but dude he didn't actually just cook it
you know no no I know uh the uh but the
uh so this was like dude we're gonna be
on a boat until like 1pm oh by the way
the gag is still working everyone's
dying laughing there's nothing new to
the bit but it's still working it's
working great
so then it was all on you after I landed
like because you're out with the group
you now know that I'm gonna drop in
but nobody else knows you had to keep
the whole yes so a thing going hold on
Mark's working his visual gag oh that's
gonna be bad Oh I thought it was gonna
squirt
you can do this you could do a whole
hour on this that was mine I got a new
stick ruin my closer hot dog cigar
Netflix coming for you
foreign
[Music]